c'est grâce à elle ses confrères
vous avez aussi été invité par robert
vous demandez certainement ce que vous
faites le chef vous lisez ce soir votre
porte ignoble spatio-temporelle entrera
en conjonction avec une faille dans le
temps ouvre un couloir entre la date et
l'heure précise de ce jour et le 18 mai
1944 arrête la cocaïne en mer
on est soixante dix ans en arrière
attention le wind qui ouvre cette porte
et l'avenir ne sera peut-être jamais le
même
mentir est ce qui vous attire du typage
partie
les semis
le vent mai 1944 à une rafle à bordeaux
ma grand mère a échappé tu cesses
kkr est prévue
français qu'il a fait une reconstitution
du village comme il était encore en
excuses et non aux ordres sont très
claires personne boissons
je n'avais pas du tout prévu vous soyez
c'est stupide
fan de l'univers combien tu l'as pris ce
n'est pas une actrice tu vois la
résistante soulignait ce gardien
je suis né en 1926
les bâtiments et l'eau